nikos aliagas vous recevez ce matin le
président du ring ding fring project
jean marc jancovici affecte donc avec
vous jean marc jancovici bonjour bonjour
vous allez sortir d'europe 1 après
l'entretien vous allez vous rendre à
l'elysée pour intégrer le haut conseil
pour le climat que mettre en place on le
dit depuis ce matin emmanuel macron
qu'allez-vous dire au président de la
république
d'abord je vais écouter ce qu'il va nous
expliquer sur ce qu'il attend de ce haut
conseil
parce que pour le moment on en a les
grandes lignes mais en à andrew la loi
mais pas encore les décrets
d'application donc pour ça que ça doit
rendre un avis sur la trajectoire de la
france en ce qui concerne la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça il ya deux
cent cinquante trois manières de rendre
en alsace à sa vaste sujet c'est un
vaste sujet absolument puisse vous
conseille pour le climat qui est
présenté aux français aujourd'hui les
présenter dans un climat aussi difficile
au niveau social dans une grotte
particulière est alors sur la partie
carburant j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement c'était prévisible parce
que non seulement le pétrole est quelque
chose qui cause des émissions de co2
contente brûle mais par ailleurs c'est
quelque chose qui est disponible en
quantité limitée sur terre et il faut
savoir que depuis 2006 la quantité de
pétrole qu'on appelle conventionnelle
donc tout ce qui ne vient pas du shale
oil américain pétrole de schiste et des
sables bitumineux canadiens n'augmente
plus c'est stable depuis 2006 est donc
tout ce que les chinois apprennent en
plus nous ont néanmoins donc
l'approvisionnement pétrolier européen
il a commencé à décroître de façon subit
depuis 2006 il ya un lien direct avec ce
qu'on a appelé la crise des subprimes ça
va ça a ralenti l'économie sans qu'on le
demande et en particulier pour les gens
qui ont besoin de beaucoup utilisé une
voiture pour se rendre au travail et
faire les courses et caetera et biya
depuis 2006 une contrainte qui va
croissant donc ce qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment était malheureusement
prévisible dans un pays
où la seule transition énergétique dont
on s'occupe vraiment mais on y reviendra
peut-être et celle concernant
l'électricité qui en plus est pas
nécessaire et on s'occupe pas du pétrole
alors que c'est nécessaire là vous nous
en parler avec voilà des données
techniques
est-ce qu'elle concerne les gens est ce
que c'est en question sont suffisantes
pour que l'on puisse rassurer la
population qui porte un gilet jaune qui
vient manifester alors là assurée à
court terme malheureusement pas enfin ça
les rassure et à courte à court terme
non parce que ce qui va se passer c'est
que la france va continuer à avoir un
approvisionnement pétrolier en tendance
qui va décroître
par contre là où on doit les rassurer
c'est sur la façon de gérer le problème
c'est à dire eh bien on peut pas dire
simplement aux gens l'essence va coûter
de plus en plus cher et débrouillez vous
donc il faut aussi pédagogie vous voulez
dire alors d'abord il faut une pédagogie
du problème qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
fait d'accord en amont et en amont donc
il faut vous invitiez plus souvent des
gens pour en parler un peu plus de six
minutes
la deuxième chose c'est qu'elle invitera
j'adore me lever tôt c'est qu'il faut
planifier les transports céder système
blanc voyez une autoroute une voie de
chemin de fer une route c'est des trucs
qui dure un siècle donc vous changez pas
ça du jour au lendemain faut que les
gens ont pris l'habitude d'habiter où
ils habitent et d'utiliser leurs
voitures pour aller au travail
tout ça c'est des systèmes qui changent
lentement donc il faut les rassurer sur
le fait qu'on va s'occuper de changer le
système
alors deux exemples il ya des tas
d'endroits où on peut mettre en place
des services de bus qui permettent aux
gens de ne pas utiliser leur voiture
accor le bus coûte trois fois moins cher
par passager transporté que la voiture
non mais vous faites des économies en
passant de la voiture au bus encore
faut-il que le bus passe devant chez
vous
oui après du à mourenx où il n'y a pas
de bus pas réellement c'est bien ce que
je dis ça s'organise d'accord faut le
vouloir
la deuxième chose c'est que vous pouvez
demander au constructeur de vendre des
voitures qui consomment de moins en
moins et vous pouvez non seulement leur
demander mais les obliger à le faire il
ya une instance en europe qui s'occupe
de réglementer les émissions de co2 par
voiture c'est à dire la consommation par
voiture c'est exactement la même chose
et on peut très bien les obliger à
vendre des voitures de plus en plus de
moins en moins gourmands n'ont en fait
de plus en plus petit
mais qui feront job et ça c'est pareil
vous changez pas une ligne de production
et la voiture électrique c'est un luxe
on entend souvent les gilets jaunes qui
le disent mais c'est un truc de bobos
vous avez de l'argent pour les acheter
nous on ne peut pas jeter la voiture
laurent coût complet aujourd'hui une
voiture électrique coûte un peu plus
cher qu'une voiture à pétrole donc ça
résout le problème du co2 mais ça résout
pas le problème du chèque de fin de mois
comment un problème climatique comment
un problème de projections concernant
notre notre quotidien est il devenu un
problème politique aujourd'hui par ce
guide c'était inévitable c'est ce que
vous nous interprète de grogne c'est pas
un problème climatique qui justifie la
grogne c'est parce que en fait il se
passe deux choses on a manqué quoi
justement le quand vous regardez le
montant de la taxe carbone aujourd'hui
par litre de carburant on est à 7
centimes et l'année prochaine on passera
à 10 centimes d'accord donc ça sur un
euro cinquante c'est pas ça qui fait
l'essentiel du prix ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment c'est que le
prix du pétrole a beaucoup monté sur ce
qu'on appelle les marchés donc pour
acheter à baril de pétrole aux gens qui
produisent ça a beaucoup monté et sarah
beaucoup monté tout simplement parce que
comme le pétrole est sous contraintes de
production depuis dix ans on passe
périodiquement par des moments où le
prix s'envolent et tant qu'on se
désintoxique pas entre guillemets du
pétrole on va avoir ce genre de truc de
manière répétée et dans désintoxication
vis-à-vis du pétrole décarbonation ou
dit oui décarbonation et mais aussi le
politique
regardez je vous lisez en 2011 dans les
échos vous écriviez marine le pen
enfants du carbone est aussi un temps
que nous conserverons cette dépendance
mortelle aux combustibles fossiles
marine le pen montera dans les sondages
oui franchement oui ça y est c'est
logique ce que vous dites ou apparentée
à celle qui leur vient de se passer non
d'accord alors là veut dire quoi
alors là c'est quoi le raisonnement
alors le raisonnement est très simple le
raisonnement c'est que quand vous avez
moins de pétrole de manière subi vous
avez moins de transport
du coup l'économie se contracte et comme
parce que l'économie dépend des
transports aujourd'hui vous avez pas une
usine qui n'est pas besoin de camions en
fait c'est si l'économie se contracte
vous éjecter des gens du monde du
travail
donc il n'aime pas ça et ont présenté
les contester par ailleurs les gens que
vous éjecter en premier c'est les gens
qui ont le plus besoin de vote
la voiture parce que c'est des gens qui
habitent à la périphérie des villes
c'est là que vous allez trouver les gens
qui gagnent le moins
donc ils sont les moins qualifiés et
c'est ce qu'ont éjectant premier du
système quand le système va pas bien et
par ailleurs c'est aussi ce qu'ont plus
besoin de la voiture pour se déplacer et
depuis les premiers chocs pétroliers
l'électorat du fn est maximale à 40 km
du centre des grandes villes il ya une
étude ifop qui avait montré sa très bien
donc c'est en cela que je disais et
quand je suis tombé sur cette étude g10
et voilà ça - roux s'occupera du pétrole
et plus on aura cette population loger
là où elle est et dépendante de
l'économie à la à la frange de
l'économie et la france périphérique
exactement si c'est elle qui est celle
qui souffre en premier quand l'économie
va pas bien parce qu'on n'a pas assez de
pétrole
vous allez dire quoi donc au président
de la république en arrivant tout cela
est bien ainsi il m'écoute aussi bien
que vous je vais essayer de lui faire
comprendre que décarbonés l'économie
c'est un projet politique extrêmement
noble qui peut être très enthousiasmant
qui rend service socialement et qui de
toute façon inexorable puisque comme je
le disais du pétrole et du gaz on va en
avoir en tendance de moins en moins dix
pièces qu'on meurt donc il faut s'en
occuper
merci jean marc jancovici d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur europe 1 avant de
rejoindre le président à l'elysée je
rappelle que vous êtes l'un des 13
membres experts du tout nouveau haut
conseil pour le climat merci beaucoup
principe
[Musique]
à